*plagiarized game theory intro*
*this is a very good intro*
*DEAD MEMES REEEEEEEEEEEEEE*
Meme review
Meme review, that's right everybody. YouTube's most voted top show, uh, thank you guys.
We did it. I'm so proud.
OBUNGA
I hope to God you will never
hear those words
OBUNGA
He sees you when you are sleeping.
Obunga. He knows if you're awake.
OBUNGA
That's right everybody, I'm talking about Obunga.
You guys heard about this? You know about this?
Obunga, everybody. You may think his name is Obama. Uh uh uH
No no no *ear rape*
Holy heck, that was super scary. Perhaps Obunga can be the next Five Nights at Freddy's.
Oh my gosh guys. Dude this is gonna get millions of hits on YouTube
Liiit
"Stop calling me Obunga." -Barack Obama
Excuse me, Barack Obama, but I see through your Obunga lies. I just realized this joke is slightly racist. Damn it.
Which makes it so much better!
That was a joke everybody. Fwoosh, the joke went right over your head.
Obunga, of course, doesn't only have to be spooky and scary.
Obunga can be — excuse me for having an opinion. Full disclaimer: don't dislike this video for me giving this opinion.
But it w̶i̶l̶l̶ ̶g̶e̶t̶  can be very cute. That's right, I said it haters.
Look at it
Adorable
I love him
You know what? I think I'll marry Obunga instead.
Sumimasen. Marzia pchh
Go to the siide. Obunga. Obunga come here.
oH my gosh
*ear rape*
If you say Obunga three times in the mirror
You wouldn't even dAre. You wouldn't even dare
if you comment "Obunga Obunga Obunga" three times and smAsh that like button on a PewDiePie video, Obunga is going to Obunga.
Okay? So don't do it. Whatever you do, do not subscribe and hit the bell button and type "Obunga Obunga Obunga. Lol it didn't work."
Now let's change the meme guys, cause this is just too scary
Uh, the new Nintendo Switch announcement came out for the new character, and it's finally
fiNAlly going to be
AhhhHhhHhhHhHhHhHH
Damn you! Stop summoning Obunga guys, please. This is not some sort of game.
Alright. Changing meme.
Hey, well okay we have a sexy girl.
Alright. Yeah, I like that. I like that.
Now this — this is epic. Okay, alright, what have we got?
szlsjlsk ah aH
Stop summoning Obunga!
Damn it!
You could kill me do you not care? Okay moving on next meme. Alright, what's the real next cares? Umm?
Smash. Alright. Oh my god, it's well Luigi, finally. Thank you Thank You Wayne
Stop it, stop with your bunga
bunga meme gets of course Olga Bunga a boo-boo
5000 obungas. That's right. I outdid all of you. goodbye next meme
What happened to meme review.
At number 13 a child
The last place you would want to lose your child is in a sewer drain
Oh, that wasn't so bad. Number 13 13 a child a child number
Number 13 a child
The last thing you want in your burger is a child who gives me the creeps. Those children
next meme Incredibles 2. Have you heard about this, you know about this you heard about this, huh Incredibles 2 star Elastigirl is
"thicc" whatever
That means why that's a good thing why people are quick to point out my god
Was elasti-girl always that thick? I mean I get it rubber is extremely attractive
Nothing that turns me on than a piece of rubberry roo.
Ooh, I like to froze it down because then it's useless and that's how I like my women
A ton of controversy. A ton of drama around Elastigirl.
Elastigirl proves superhero women can come in both thicc and thin
Finally a progressive film
Finally, when is a Disney star going to prove that it's okay to be thick and thin I've asked this a million times
Finally, we have a superhero where every man who's in true intellect can agree that damn
She is thick. Comments like "mrs. Incredible has got some thick booty"
"Mrs.Incredible can get this D later, I swear"
" she does have a nice ass." "she thick heart heart heart". She is
Extra thick and of course what's very incredible
is that ass. The Incredibles more like the indigestible
I mean, it looks like there's something wrong with her. Should we be concerned?
finally
A Disney movie that troubles indigestion. A lot of people seem to be surprised about this
Somehow acting like Miss aunty from robot didn't exist
Hey perverts, of course is always gotta be the contrarians
Hey perverts. Stop staring at Elastigirls butt. You can't stop me.
Oh Yeah mainstream media? I don't think so
but the most shameless display of appreciation for
Elastigirls butt has to be this article from The New Yorker. "Incredibles 2 review" by
Anthony Lane and can we get some classy music, please?
Listen carefully and you may just hear a shifty sound as of parents
squirming awkwardly beside their enraptured offspring and why kids
Because mommy just leaned over to Daddy and whispered. Is it just me or does
Mrs.Incredible kind of look like, Anastasia in Fifty Shades of Grey
you know the girl in the red room with a whips on all? and daddy just
Rested... Jesus Christ
Just rested his cooling soda firmly on his lap and like
Mr. Incredible tried very hard to think of algebra
this is a review for a kids movie as for how daddy will react later on during the scene in which
Helen in the husky boys Evelyn's earned wind and simply talk
Woman-to-woman. I hate to think but watch out for flying
popcorn
from my diiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiii
Of course
Of course, there's people shaming The New Yorker. Holy crap
What's with the new New Yorker review of The Incredibles. Gross.
Amanda Wong more like Amanda Wrong
You're wrong about- I didn't mean for that to come off racist. I just realized it
So I will retract the joke everybody now, which is gone
Let's forget about that one. Incredibles 2 reviewed a sequel in the shadow of a masterwork
They might as well call this I want to F the cartoon
The Incredibles 2 review by Anthony Lane is very good
But what I personally prefer is the minions 2 review. I want to F a minion
fist bump the screen right now if you want to as well. Hell yeah
And all this controversy about butts this and butts that?
What's really really important here, the real message that we need to channel our anger towards,
Is the fact that they nerfed Snakes ass!
Is no one talking about this? Is no one even gonna bring this up?
Look how thick that left is and look how ugh
I don't even want to look at snake's ass anymore before I could enjoy the snake games this
Now I can't enjoy the snake games and if we're gonna talk about thickness
I wanna end this on this note by melon himself. Damn
Damn boy
I'm not gonna read this mean because it's too important if I watch out for flying popcorn it gets a flying popcorn
The next meme is a man walking on the street. Wait a minute
Is this loss? oh my gosh
Successful people
Unsuccessful people people who thanked, the bus driver when they get up. That's right everybody
Are you part of the secret elite the taught that 1% of the 1%
That thanks the bus driver when you get off cuz I do every time and that's how I know
My grave will have plated gold in Egyptian style in my own little dungeon. Anxiety
What if you're not good enough? Depression: everyone hates you. Bus driver: Hey, you forgot to thank me. Oh no
No, this has not happen to me. Number one. We text all the time. Ok, and he's saved as
Mr. Bus driver xx. Love you xx number two
I will never never forget to pass and thank that bus driver never. Cultural people. Have a nice day
Have a nice weekend. See ya. Thank you. All these things must be said to the bus driver
Otherwise don't even consider yourself an intellectual. Ok. This is what you see
Mm-hmm a regular potato chip you might say
Well, this is what I see and other fellow members that thank the bus driver
Okay, it's an hyperbolic
Paraboloid and everybody knows that and you could know it too. You just have to thank the bus driver. Hey
Don't make me pull a gun on you. You will thank the bus driver. I'm doing this for you
not for me. If you're a virgin, you might consider thanking the bus driver because it gets women going
Oh la la. Ooh la la very nice
So from zero from zero from verging to ha ha very good. Saying thanks to the bus driver
Giving bus driver some shrimp. That is also acceptable in some cultures, of course
You got to make sure that you study up on these things. Are you writing this down? Are you even paying attention?
LMAO, that kid doesn't even thank the bus driver
*high pitch voice* OMG what an effin virgin
What's the matter Ethan too much of a pussy to
To venerate working class icons. Ah, you're not even venerating working class icons
Ethan Ethan Ethan hate that name, never liked that name. Saying thank you to the bus driver. Yes, of course
Yes
Of course 1% 1% but asking the bus driver how their day was
1% 1% 1% of people
but the top of the top the CEO of the CEOs the world
presidents of the universe offered the bus driver a
Ride home
Thank you everybody
I hope this has been
educational for you as it has for me. Leave a like if you enjoyed this video and make sure to rate this meme a
Thank you to the bus driver everybody. My name is
Felix kajal burg and you've just been phill'd in I see you tomorrow *byee*